you
[Music]
q yeah this is a new package it's only
been released last December made public
we've actually been working on since
March it's not just me it's gonna be
also Barrett who's over there and George
hang huge contributions from them to
make this possible
so yeah richness is my name making GT is
my game apparently and I'm available on
Twitter email github all the places okay
so the GT package lets you build display
tables with easy news functions now the
key was easy we want to make these
functions easy to use and follow tip his
success really table outputs they can be
HTML latech that's how I pronounced that
an RTF mmm now the first time I saw RTF
it was a real WTF so I'm hoping you
never have to do that yourself generate
RTF code it's actually just Hill so the
package is available on github it's
gonna be a while until we get it on on
cran we just really want to get the
internals right so the basic workflow is
you got just a table data this could be
a table or a data frame and you
introduced it the GT and it becomes a GT
object and you can use all the functions
inside GT there's lots to modify the
table what you get in the end is a GT
table and that again is HTML the tag or
RTF that could be our markdown we've
done the console
wherever okay when we first sat out to
make this package we thought what are
some useful features and display tables
what are we bringing to the table as it
were first things come off yes the table
header it's nice to have a title and a
subtitle it's fantastic it's or identify
the table describes it we had to have
that so we put that in row labels so
here's a cool thing we got cars and we
have his countries these countries where
the cars came from so we basically have
like groups of rows will call them row
groups so it allows you sort of
structure your your roses essentially
it's quite nice and this is probably
more familiar as column labels just
having columns banners over certain
columns so here we can see performance
going over top of
a few other columns a really big thing
is data formatted we want to make it
super easy to have your data transformed
to any way you want this is actually a
GT table so as you can see here the data
of course isn't coming this way you
format yourself and there's easy ways to
target different cells and to make the
formatting easy and this was a big one
footnotes
I love footnotes the idea you can put a
little notice you can annotate your
table a real nightmare sometimes making
a table is like in in the right order so
GT always puts in the right order we
don't have to have to worry about order
you specify the footnotes GT will handle
it so you can see right here for those
are kind of small Etsy so I call them
out it's always gonna be left to right
top down in terms of numbering I think
you see the notes at the bottom they're
also an order so you don't worry about
order when you're doing footnotes in GT
so in order to make this work
really well we need to define a
structure for a table some sort of like
structures I'll solve 90% of your table
needs so we call them table parts so the
most basic table is this it's very
familiar
you got column labels you get a table
body tail body has cells it's arranged
in columns and rows very very familiar
it's the most basic form of the table
but here's a cool thing a stub it's it's
a little known term in table technology
it's just a it's essentially like row
names but we can do better than row
names like in data frames we can have a
stub that defines we can have labels for
each row again it's not always needed
but it can be useful in certain
circumstances like if rows are
representing some sort of thing that you
want to call out and because we can
conceivably have groups of rows it's
nice we can have space there for a rogue
group label that extends out into the
table body which is really quite nice
and a feature of GT is creating summary
rows so if you have summary rows you can
have summary labels you can identify
what are in the summary cells it could
be like an average or range
what-have-you it's nice to describe what
that is otherwise you wouldn't really
know so at the top we have a table
header it's a great place to add a title
and a subtitle
at the best place really and the bottom
is the footer area that's where you
throw in the footnotes as many as you
want and source notes so it's like a
special type of note that just you can
use it for all sorts of things but
typically use it to just you know see
the source of the data or other things
other low notes that are not really
labeled okay so the question you might
be asking is do we have the functions to
get these display display tables made
yes totally do we have lots of functions
that's why it took so long to get this
package okay and we're just writing
functions like crazy so the main one is
GT that's how you introduce your table
data to GT so it's great you have table
data again Tibble of data frame just
pipe into GT and you got that object and
just right there it looks pretty good
I'll show you some demos the second the
back half of this talk is like a live
coding situation inside our studio which
is always risky but I like to live
dangerously so yeah it may be the case
where your table data is huge
it doesn't mean you know it's not really
summarized but luckily we have tools
like Toddie are deep fire at the toddy
verse we can you know summarize our data
do cool things to it
reshape it and then when it's ready then
you bring the GT for the final touches
as it were so we have lots of families
of functions I know just introduce you
to two families we have these tab
underscore functions and these are just
concerned with adding parts to a table
so they're all targeting a different
element so a tab header is routing table
header spanner is routing spanner
columns and tab footnote is for adding
footnotes as many as you want we have a
series of formatter functions they all
begin with fmt underscore and these are
great for making the data appear as you
want them to appear it's kind of like an
Excel where you're just selecting a
bunch of cells and you're just applying
a format it's the same sort of like idea
here I'll walk you through a few of
these just to show you what they do
formatting numbers it's really simple
use format number here's a
before-and-after sort of shot of like
the data so we have this column right
here it's got some data it's two three
decimal places
and you can use format number just put
in the argument decimals equals one and
yeah we have it to one decimal place and
even throw us in a comma for you what
you can disable as well so GT knows
about currencies and - Ashley focals -
is crazy so it can do all sorts of
currencies you just provide a currency
code which is easier to look up and we
actually have a function that gives you
a table currency codes and yeah past use
currency format currency and then that
before column becomes a set of currency
code instead of currencies right here
and the locale here just ensures that
the formatting is correct for the locale
here are using French in France so mm-hm
there may be some mas in your data and
they appear in GTS na s those can be
replaced you just use format missing
choose some replacement text in the
default case we just use an M - and it
looks pretty good in a presentation
table but you can choose any sort of
like text that you want and target any
sort of andis that are applicable for
that text okay there's tons more
functions there's just no time to even
mention here I gotta move quickly
because I really want to get into like
the sort of live coding bit which is
going to happen in a sec mmm
tons of demos I want to show you the GT
Patchett GT package Ashley comes with
six example data sets country pops SCA
GT cars SP 500 pizza plays and exhibit
we're just gonna take a look at some
simple examples with the exhibit dataset
it's an example of table it's only eight
rows but it's great for making little
small tables it's just the right size
and we use on the pizza place dia set so
we're gonna summarize out a bit because
it's a huge ace at a fifty thousand rows
take that use a bunch of functions on it
get in line HTML and this is like the
secret sauce you need to send an email
we need to put the chunk HTML to
so let's head on over to our studio
which I have here okay so we have two
packages we need GT and toddy verse can
everybody see this especially the back
do I have to pump up the font no pump it
up okay I'm gonna do that one sec here
spare with me while I go into crafts
what's the usual 18
does anybody know this oh yeah yeah well
okay hang on how about tomorrow you like
tomorrow yeah okay better than tomorrow
night okay okay that's visible right
almost everybody okay perfect okay so
let's have a look at Sibyl it's a yeah
dataset so I'm just gonna bring this a
little bit it's just a bros so the
futures here is that we can use these
different columns just to experiment
with the API and GT and importantly we
have this these two categorical columns
row in group we can use those to
actually trade row labels and actually
create the groups like row groups so
let's look at exhibit just pipe to the
GT by itself how it looks I mean not bad
you know you have the table as it looks
there some row striping it's reasonable
its HTML but here's the cool thing we
can create a stub with row labels and
include row groups just by having a few
arguments to GT being used this is
ruining home we're just passing in
column names here so let's try this see
what we get yeah there we go
so here's the stuff right here and
here's the ropes say group a a groupie
and different rows inside those groups
cool so now we're gonna do a bunch of
like the little function test here and
we can sort of play around cuz we're you
know live you know coding environment so
here's a function that's great format
scientific so if you wanna do some
seismic notation this is nice
all you have to do is supply the column
name we wrap that in bars all the way so
we have
this case three and so this is going to
act on the num column let's have a look
and see how its scientific notation
looks it's a bit nicer right it's got
the times ten to the power of as you can
see here so there isn't that any
notation you get by default so we can
also format dates in this date column
right here so we have date says iso
formatted dates right here to sort of
they're just as like character text
essentially so here's a really cool
thing we can specify the column date but
we can also specify rows and provide a
condition in this case we're looking at
the column char and there's a number of
different fruits here so we're just
saying for the columns in char I started
the rows and Charro that begin with a to
D that's the those are the cells were
going to format right here in date and
we're using Dave Stalin six I'll show
you about these dollars in a second here
but just see how that works yeah see
there we go so it's isolated ecchi cells
so we can target certain cells just by
using combination of columns and rows so
mmm taste aisle six how we know that
it's actually a good day style we can
use these info functions that give you a
table they allow you to like sort of see
what the different styles are there we
go
it's info table and right here this is
number six that's we've used and that's
how this date would be formatted that's
great we got a ton of other info tables
too like info currencies because you
know who knows all the currency codes
info time styles because you might want
to format times and here's a really
really cool one we can use colors inside
GT to color cells with the data color
function and uses palettes but this is a
great way to discover all these palettes
and essentially this is from the palette
to your package which is fully supported
in here so tons and tons of like colors
you can explore just inside GT ok mmm
so we can get rid of some columns too if
you find that we don't need them just by
using this calls hide function okay so
let's try that let's get rid of these
columns which are factor time daytime
and see what that looks like
okay now we have a narrow bro table for
sure it just hit those columns because
their head they're still usable in the
these expressions that rely on other
columns so it just means they're not
being displayed at the end but they're
still useable for you know all sorts of
things so we have a something called
currency it's not really as currencies
right now we can format to be currencies
so it uses the format currency function
here so we're gonna specify this column
provide the currency code and this will
become currencies in pounds there we go
now here's my favorite thing adding
footnotes as I said before uses have
footnote function there's a it's a bit
more complicated cuz you're targeting
potentially and you learn the table to
put a footnote so we have this locations
argument and it takes a number of
location helper functions so we have
cells underscore data cells underscore
column labels title all sorts of things
like that it just allows you to target
where you want to put the footnote
didn't it attaches it to the end of the
text so this case we're using cells data
cuz we want to target some data and the
interfaces that we have columns and rows
it's just like be it for matters in this
case we can provide an expression
provide some column name and so it's
going to attach to currencies where the
value is less than 20 so just because
these are format it doesn't mean that
value is still not there it's an
immutable table inside the actual object
so we can still use the values so
anything less than 20 will get this
footnote these are lower prices at the
bottom it's really small sorry about
that but it's there okay we're gonna add
one more footnote to the currency column
label itself we're gonna attach it right
to the column label oftentimes you want
to do that so we'll use cells column
labels and just provide the column name
and here's a really cool thing we're
providing this second but it's gonna
auto order the footnotes see it's become
one here and too for all these other
ones it changes it doesn't matter what
order we present these footnotes in it's
sort of like just listens to you and
handles item in the end great
one thing I've neglected is to add a
title to the table and a subtitle so I'm
going to do that just for this oh yeah I
want explain that you can throw and mark
down here just use the MD helper and
then we have this rendered as code and
being bold right there so let's have a
look at that great yeah see if I were to
not do this just like get rid of this
maybe just make it talax
like that it will just become an italics
yeah great okay there's all sorts of
other options sort of stowed away in tab
options it's huge I love you see the
pop-up texts its truncated because
there's like millions of arguments but
basically can change almost all aspects
of the table you can style things one
aspect one thing you can change is the
footnote glyph you can it say if you
tire of like numbers they can just be
letters so let's try that
great you're really hard to see because
footnotes are tiny but these become they
became a and B because we care this
could be letters or letters like that so
it's a whole big success thing so trying
to get easy and although this is not
easy you have to know what this is but I
can see this is gonna be a vignette one
day just describing what these options
are there's lots of them but essentially
this one allows you to color the
background of the column labels blue
okay
that was kinda see let's do with the hat
what happens there okay turn blue but
the cool thing is the text turn white it
does that for you because it wants to
give you the maximum contrast so it does
that with s CSS in the background if it
doesn't do it with that it does a bit
some code so it's trying to give you the
best looking table we possibly can and
because we're in a track that cares
about arm rock down here's the whole
thing in our markdown I'm just going to
knit it and we'll see how it looks all
right all the chunks have been processed
here it is in HTML all the chunks are
there and here's all the tables as HTML
again you can do this as as PDF just
change the output type as RTF if you
dare and it's a dull there alright good
now the final thing sending the email I
don't know like getting an email it
could be kind of cool it's gonna be the
right type of email like it
if I had an email with a table in it
that does useful that would be kind of
cool so it's a load a bunch of packages
here that are concerned with that sort
of thing and we're just going to set
this up I'm not gonna just gloss over
this as much as I can because it's not
important it's just getting sort of
stuff for the email body itself so but I
won't unless where this is all let's
look at pizza place it's one my favorite
day of Science in its package fifty
thousand rows it's like a year of Pisa
sales essentially every transaction in
that year of the fictional pizza place
so we've got this huge data frame or
table if you were to render this indeed
in GT it would be massive just be a long
table nobody wants that so let's do some
deep fryer I'm not going to go through
the details but if you just you know run
this code up to here we'll see that the
end table becomes a more manageable 14
rows which looks great for a GT table so
I'm gonna pass that right into GT yeah
and there it is we're do a few more
things and I'll show you what that looks
like right here great fantastic very
nice you can't put a Bochy and that's
pretty fun and here's the cool thing as
right raw HTML that makes it mailable so
we just we can just create this email
we'll preview it right inside our studio
and then I'm gonna flip over to my
private email this is a I won't show you
my embarrassing emails but I'll show you
like just like this one message here it
is it came across like full fidelity the
emojis there Keaton slices they're all
the colors are there that's an email and
YC I mean this is important stuff Pizza
sales yeah so that's about it I'm gonna
go back to our studio I'm sorry to
keynote here because we're done and yeah
if you want more information go to the
repo it's a github calm our studio /gt
this very presentation is a my sir is in
my personal github if you want to see
that and all the data is there and
otherwise thanks
[Applause]
thank you very much we've got time for
some questions do you want to hit the
turn around and say oh good you're
catching is okay give us your name in
your question please yeah my name is
Klaus so this was great my question is
more of a request I think you'd make a
lot of analysts eternally grateful if
you could add Excel output yes I've been
asked for various things Excel Word
plain text these are all in the pipeline
for now we really just want to
concentrate on game parity between the
format's I specified HTML latech and RTF
because right now certain things are
ignored between them I'm going to get
sort of like style parity between them
the whole idea is that you you write at
once and hopefully depending on your
context it just works
it may ignore a few things or or not but
essentially it should be compatible with
portable across the types but once
that's sort of done in the next few
months we're gonna focus on where output
types even things like SVG like natively
it's just we have high hopes for this
okay and we've got one more question
from the back please
hi my name is Kamal I was just wondering
can we merge two shells is that
functionality in there it's there yeah
dissipation that haven't happened just
one more can I create my own format
stable formats and apply that to a table
yeah yes just everything awesome there's
a there's a there's a format function
which you can use to wrap make your own
function of it but essentially what it's
very flexible we're gonna make a
vignette out of that but essentially
what you do is you provide your own code
for all the different contexts which is
default HTML RTF as many as you want and
depending on the context you're in it'll
format like that you just use a default
as well but yeah you can totally do that
it basically just relies on a vector
it's a vector processing essentially all
right thank you
you
[Music]